oh hi this is gonna be an interesting
video it's part of boxing video I wanted
to talk about wireless accessories for
your new phone it's worked out perfect
because almost all of the wireless stuff
that I use for my phone and to charge is
from OFI and holy moly this is heavy I
I'm not even sure what's in here they
were releasing a bunch of wireless
products in the past couple of years so
now I feel like since the iPhone
starting with I guess last year's iPhone
the iPhone 10 has wireless charging
enabled most phones nowadays either
habits or most funds going forward will
have it there's oh my gosh no way this
is so cool
wow this is like a little dresser
there's drawers I'm so excited to open
this up a huge thank you to movi for
partnering with me on this video I am so
excited to show you some new of their
charge stream products I want to be
surprised I don't like to know what's
inside of something before I open it up
also in case you were interested if you
did decide to get anything from the
charge stream line for mow feet there is
a discount code you can use I just need
for 20% off any of the charge stream
products anything that we're going
through here for you my friends let's
see what's in the top drawer
the first thing that we have is the
charge stream is to the power station
Wireless and power station Wireless
Excel so most of the time I usually
carry one of these around but you always
need a cable so this has a USB a and a
USB C but the best part about it you
don't even need a cable if your phone
has wireless charging so the lighter
breck will give you 48 hours of battery
life and the smaller one will give you
34 this is something that I do not have
yet this is a wireless charger for your
car oh yeah I'm putting this in my car
immediately
the one that I have now it's not a
charger but it does attach to the vent
and my phone it slips down and then it
hits the restart buttons and then it's
calling the emergency services so I have
one of these when they first came out
this size Apple fast charge and we'll
also do samsung bass charge
I love these charging pads I have them
all around my house I have them on my
desk I have in my my nightstand I have
some downstairs for guests and they're
perfect because they are so small it
kind of just look like coffee cup
coasters which I definitely wouldn't
recommend putting your coffee on it but
if you wanted to you can Who am I to
tell you what to do just pops right on
there like so and charges your phone
they also have these in white okay if
they you don't have a picture but this
is one of the charge stream hide plusses
so this does have a faster charge and
the previous version when they first
came out with them next drawer this is
like what is it do you or no deal
dream travel kit Universal 100 hello I'm
obsessed with small tiny little bags
like this
everything that I travel with has like a
tiny little package that keeps
everything inside of it separate from
other things so this is so cool
I've got everything that I could
possibly need I've got a micro USB cable
I would probably throw in a lightning
cable a USB C in here because I like to
make sure I have everything oh this is
good for road trips look at this tiny
little car charging port you've got just
a regular charging brick DC is cool it's
like a super small little charging wedge
it's not plugged into it's obviously not
starting perfect for traveling Oh little
accessories for the car adapter we've
got the car charger UB also this is cool
you can mount on your dashboard it's got
a little tape right there so you're able
to put that on your dashboard this is to
extend from the dashboard mount so if
you want to have it a little bit further
out a wall adapter for my stream pad oh
my gosh the rest of the accessories I'm
such a sucker for cables this is
exciting
I'm actually heading to the airport in
30 minutes so you better believe I'm
packing all of these goodies I also want
to go over a few other wireless things
that I've been using with my phone these
aren't necessarily chargers these are my
most favorite recent tech things that I
got this is the JBL pulse this is device
it's battery-powered you obviously have
to plug it in to charge it but this is
so fun because we've just been carrying
these things around the house we take
them to friends houses and the best part
about it is it lights up and it looks
cool in the background of videos it
sounds good too there's an east-side
acoustic
[Music]
Benny is my new favorite person to fall
in with social media I think that we
would probably be friends if we met in
real life I'm not sure either way music
is crazy it's really funny it's just
still reminds me of like a really cool
drink another thing that I am obsessed
with this is a DJI copilot they partly
with lacy to make this hard drive that
you can basically insert an SD card and
if you're out about so right now we're
out on this beautiful lake flying drones
and we don't have a computer with us so
we can put an SD card in here copy all
of the footage onto this hard drive and
then I can plug this into my phone and I
can download all of the videos all of
the photos I'm taking a hyperlapse right
now and it's almost completed
[Music]
no computer guys this is magic it's
copying eight of eighty so here's the
copilot this is the actual drive so I
just copied all of these files to it so
here's where I could choose that I just
saved here's the video oh my god that's
an incredible shot maybe you were so
close to that boat these are the Bose
QuietComfort 35 series - noise
cancelling headphones it's been a while
since I had a really good pair of
headphones you since I got the ear pods
that's all I use now they are good
headphones but they're not noise
cancelling and these are super high
quality so these have been my travel
companion for the past month or so
and the quality is incredible it's also
cool because this bluetooth can connect
to not only my phone but also my laptop
at the same time so it switches very
very quickly and I'm not constantly
having to reconnect things but the sound
quality so good for flights it's the
absolute best because I don't have to
hear children crying I don't have to
hear the sound of myself breathing I can
just listen to my tunes
fall asleep I'm curious do any of you
guys have trouble falling asleep on
flights because I sometimes do but most
of the time I will pass out before the
plane even takes off it's like you look
over I'm drooling on myself and I'm in
the most Awkward uncomfortable position
well that does it for some of my
favorite wireless things that I've been
loving recently a huge thank you to
Mophie these are incredible I think it's
definitely a game changer if you are
always on the go even if you're not on
the go half the time I'm sitting on the
couch and I'm charging my phone with one
of these power bricks again I'll put a
link in the description if you guys want
to check out any of these things and
don't forget to use I just Ginette check
out if you want to get 20% off any of
the charge stream products that I talked
about today so that's it I'm gonna go
finish packing hopefully get to the
airport on time so many fun gadgets I'm
so excited for the future it's like you
see the cool things that are being
released and coming out now but can you
imagine think about it five years
years a cool tech that we're gonna have
oh I don't mean a retirement home
[Music]